♪ ♪ ♪
- Le site est superbe et,
depuis une trentaine d'années,
il est presque oublié. À 20 km
du Mont-Tremblant, l'ancienne
pisciculture de Saint-Faustin,
fermée en 1992, redeviendra une
attraction dans les Laurentides.
NICOLAS JOLY, directeur, enviro.
et parcs, MRC des Laurentides
- Derrière moi, dans le bâtiment
principal, sera le point de
départ de ce qu'on va appeler...
de ce qu'on appelle le Sentier
des cimes, une première
en Amérique du Nord. Donc ça va
être une passerelle au niveau
de la cime des arbres qui va
se promener près de 1 km
dans la forêt avant d'arriver
à une tour d'observation
qui est à 40 mètres de hauteur
qui va permettre d'avoir une vue
360 degrés sur toute la région
des Laurentides.
- Les travaux sont commencés,
de la petite route du village,
qui en bien besoin, jusqu'à
la montagne où sera construit le
projet. L'ouverture est prévue
pour l'été 2022. Le promoteur,
une compagnie allemande, a déjà
neuf sites du genre en Europe,
et la tour de Saint-Faustin
ressemblera beaucoup à celle-ci,
située en Slovénie.
Le Sentier des cimes sera ouvert
en toutes saisons et on espère
y accueillir jusqu'à
400 000 visiteurs par année.
ARIANE PARÉ-LE GAL,
copropriétaire, Gourmet Sauvage
- On partait avec l'idée que
c'était un très, très gros
projet, peut-être un peu même
envahissant au départ.
Finalement, on s'est rendus
compte que ça demeure très
paisible et très silencieux.
Puis ça, ça nous a beaucoup plu
parce que ça vient vraiment...
c'est vraiment en accord avec
les activités que nous on mène.
- Ariane Paré-Le Gal a visité
deux des sites européens pour
se préparer. Son entreprise, qui
vend des produits de la forêt,
est déjà installée sur
le terrain de la pisciculture.
- Le contact avec la nature,
c'est beaucoup plus que
simplement se promener parmi
les arbres; c'est comprendre
notre environnement. Et puis ça,
bien, on a la ferme intention
d'y contribuer par l'éducation,
en donnant des ateliers gratuits
aux gens qui vont venir.
- Ce sera donc une nouvelle
attraction touristique
pour les Laurentides, de plus
en plus visitées. Mont-Tremblant
accueille 3 millions de
touristes par année. La piste
du P'tit Train du Nord qui passe
juste à côté du futur Sentier
des cimes a vu son achalandage
augmenter de 40 % en 2020.
- C'est sûr, l'effet COVID
dans tout ça, mais on sent cet
engouement-là puis la croissance
de la popularité sur tous les
réseaux, à toutes les régions de
notre territoire. Des sentiers
qui étaient une petite entrée
perdue deviennent soudainement
populaires de façon
exponentielle.
- Mais la région continue à se
privatiser. Condos et résidences
de luxe poussent partout
et les accès publics à la nature
deviennent plus rares.
Le Sentier des cimes est bien
accueilli par les résidents que
nous avons rencontrés.
- Il y a beaucoup
d'autres projets hôteliers
et tout vers la montagne,
mais pour diversifier,
ce serait vraiment bien.
- Les développeurs qui vont
prendre tous nos endroits verts
pour faire des développements,
ça se passe partout!
- C'est sûr que quand on est
installés, c'est facile de dire:
on veut pas que les autres
viennent. C'est un peu égoïste.
- La MRC des Laurentides se
prépare aussi à relancer le parc
Éco, un immense territoire
public grand comme 2500 terrains
de football également situé
à Saint-Faustin.
On y trouve quatre lacs.
Et leurs passerelles aquatiques,
devenues vétustes,
doivent être reconstruites.
NANCY PELLETIER, directrice
générale, MRC Laurentides
- Il a très peu de plans d'eau
accessibles actuellement.
Ce sont effectivement
les propriétaires riverains
qui s'approprient, justement,
même s'ils sont nombreux,
des lacs de la région. Et
évidemment, on essaie de donner
accès à ces plans d'eau là.
- Le parc Éco offre déjà un
camping, plusieurs sentiers de
randonnée et 20 refuges perchés
où c'est possible de dormir à
l'année. Mais cet espace, plus
reculé, demeure encore méconnu.
La MRC veut l'exploiter
davantage et elle a des projets
pour les cinq prochaines années.
- Ça peut être des habitations
sur l'eau. Actuellement, on a
des habitations dans les arbres.
Ça peut être un autre type
de camping, ça peut être
l'initiation à la pêche, ça peut
être également une cabane
à sucre nouveau genre.
- 4 millions $ devront être
investis et Québec sera
sollicité. Les Laurentides
offriront donc de nouveaux accès
aux lacs et à la forêt
québécoise. Un immense atout
quand on est la cour arrière
de Montréal.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada,
Saint-Faustin-Lac-Carré.